all right it is one of the best
restaurants in town one of my personal
favorites known for the incredible menu
from chef and owner James Street and the
food is not the only star there joining
me now to talk about some of the
Fantastic summer cocktails on their
menus is Esther's kitchen bar manager
Tucker say John welcome thank you so
much thanks for having us I was just
saying you look familiar and you're like
you probably see me in the restaurant
I'm always there behind the bar
absolutely and your cocktails are second
to none and you have a new summer menu
that just came out we do yes so we
launched a menu seasonally so every four
months so we just launched this this one
a couple months about a month ago okay
so we're gonna make one here in just a
second but first of all let me point out
the famous Esther's kitchen bread if you
haven't had this bread you haven't truly
lived this is like the best bread in the
world right it's that good I think so oh
man I love it okay but let's talk about
some of the cocktails here these are
really beautiful and fresh I'm like
getting all these fragrances here what
do we have definitely so on our left
here we have our namda Plum this is a
little play on words of the Nam the
plume it's a it's a white Sangria with
Plum and grapefruit and then this one is
going to be uh who doesn't like tequila
lime and watermelon so it goes right it
works really well these are pretty uh
pretty good sellers here everyone seems
to like them but our whole menu is
fantastic now we have something that
we're going to make here and I like the
name of it tell me about the name and
how do you come up with these Cocktails
so we work together the whole team makes
about 30 cocktails we Whittle it down to
10 for the menu and find out what works
best with our with our food menu to do
pairings okay this one has a cute name
what is it so this is the in for a penny
um that's one of my favorite phrases in
for a penny and for a pound we just we
just go for things right I like it for
Penny yeah it's um it just came to me
while I was making this cocktail up and
it's uh it's stuck this is a Tucker
special uh we could call it that okay
right what are we putting in there so
right here I have a prosciutto washed
Mezcal so we take um all the shavings
from the prosciutto that we cut fresh
daily and we let it sit with mezcal for
a little bit get and get the flavor all
worked up into it and so you get this
kind of really uh sweet Savory awesome
flavor to the Mezcal some smokiness too
like prosciutto meat oh yeah oh my gosh
how cool okay we only have less than a
minute so I want to make sure we make
this that's amazing common uh common
snack is a prosciutto melon so I have a
little bit of melon in here some lemon
and um it's a pretty good cocktail
actually so does it taste meaty it does
it does have a little bit of that meaty
flavor you'll find out in a second it's
um it it is more Savory I would say I am
excited to try this one so I should
enjoy we have a little bit of salt on
the room there just to accent that
prosciutto because of course the sugar
is going to be a bit salty for you yeah
in for a penny yeah for a penny one of
uh how many new cocktails one of ten we
have ten on the menu
um basically all the time
oh my gosh that's fantastic I'm glad you
like it I'm in for a quarter on this one
I hope so go check them out at Esther's
kitchen we'll be right back thank you
wow this is